hey everyone I'm John Luke and I'm here
with Michael Heim at summer game Fest
and Michael you got hands on with Mortal
Kombat one yes I sure did probably one
of the the biggest games show that was
probably the the flashiest and uh most
gory game at the show
I do just like what's what'd you see
what'd you play what's new tell me all
about it okay so Mortal Kombat 1 there's
actually a lot that's different from MK
11. I think one of the initial
Impressions from the trailer that you
saw during the Showcase was that oh it
looks very similar to mk11 then they
showed you the Cameo characters which
are assists that you can summon into the
match and they're all based on older
versions or like the original versions
of those characters but they kind of um
they change up the formula a little bit
because they can either depending on who
it is they can break you out of a combo
so they have combo breakers in this game
and they can also like be uh have
launchers too and they can add to your
combos the key juggling uh you're and
keeping your combo going which is which
is great and I got to experience a
little bit of that just in like the 20
30 minutes that I was playing but I
think it all speaks to the design
philosophy of MK1 and speaking to Ed
Boone was that he wanted to have a Moral
Combat that feels a lot more fast a lot
more loose because if you pay attention
to mk11 especially in the competitive
scene is that it was a much more
defensive game it was a much slower game
and that was delivered that was how it
was designed but they wanted to break
out of that shell and that's what MK1 is
doing and even from playing it and then
probably what you've seen from the
gameplay so far is that there are a lot
of there's a big aerial game a lot of
air Combos and you don't really think of
that from Mortal Kombat necessarily so
Cameo characters are part of that mix
they're part of that part of that design
now this is a fighting game so it does
take time to fully understand the
Dynamics of these new systems but I was
I was also impressed with how much each
character has changed since mk11 and
speaking to Ed again that he wanted the
team to rethink how the characters play
so for example Katana her projectiles
her fans have different properties
instead of just being a straight
projectile you can control them in
different ways you can throw them and
kind of throw off the throw off your
opponent they curve in different ways
Liu Kang being a fire god that has also
reflected in his moveset so he has a lot
of wild projectiles you know I was like
he throws summons a a dragon on the
ground that can be that is a low
projectile that he has a traditional
fireballs and you know all all his wild
kicks that you know from the other games
so it's building on the things you know
about each character and some uh it's a
fascinating ways but I think the most
interesting part for me was playing
kenshi so kenshi was not in mk11 yeah
but he has been in previous games so
he's being reintroduced and
I think he's the most interesting
character but he's the most complex
character that you've seen in Mortal
Kombat in a really long time and so I
asked Ed Boone about it and he mentioned
that Mortal Kombat has always banked on
being one of the more simple Fighters
the it's easier to execute certain moves
so it's uh it's not like you're doing
double quarter circles or doing these uh
wild air combos with jump cancels on all
that so uh kenshi is a lot more of a
technical character he's a little bit
more complex than what you may remember
from previous Mortal Kombat games and
that's because he is mostly a puppet
character so he can summon a spirit that
you can control separately and can like
have at the same time so it adds this
extra layer that I think is going to be
really interesting and I'm curious how
it's going to play out in the Meta Even
from just my experience so far my brief
time playing as kenshi I was already
figuring out ways to summon him and he
could be he can kind of act like a
projectile because you can some some in
him from from the top of the screen to
to do a high attack or you can move him
so the so he's his spirit is behind your
opponent while you're attacking from the
front and speaking about you know
playing a lot more loose and having air
combos like that there are some wild
things that you can do with kenshi I'm
not gonna lie I put the CPU difficulty
on very hard playing against kenshi I
already saw some of the wild things that
you can do with him in addition to the
Cameo characters and Ed Boon had also
mentioned that you know you're
essentially worried about three
characters if you play kenshi his Spirit
The Cameo character and the characters
yeah and it's it's really surprising to
see Mortal Kombat move in this direction
but I do think it's necessary to to
break out of that shell and distinguish
itself from mk11 and it's had a good run
but I think watching the competitive
scene you've seen like people have
they've downloaded the game they've
figured it out but this adds another
layer of complexity a lot more depth and
I think that the the whole story about
the time reset and these LL universes
and Liu Kang being a god it gives them a
clean slate to rethink how these
characters work in combat yeah but also
incorporate that into like the the crazy
story that they the stories that they
always tell so yeah I think both
gameplay and story-wise from what I
spoke with Ed about and just a brief
Hands-On I got and the trails that we
saw MK1 is it feels like the the most
that the game has like broke broken out
of its traditional style while still
channeling all the things that you
probably remember and love from Mortal
kombat's past well thank you very much
Michael uh we do not have long to wait
to get our hands on the game ourselves
because it comes out on September 19th
but we got a ton of gameplay we have the
interview you did with Ed Boone all up
on gamespot.com and YouTube so go check
that out and for more on Mortal Kombat
one stay right here with GameSpot
[Music]